The House of Representatives will be voting later
this month on whether to make Washington, D.C.,
the fifty first state of the United States.
CBS News reporting that House Majority Leader
Steny Hoyer wrote in a letter to colleagues two,
three days ago that at some point during April,
the House will hold a vote. Do we make Washington,
D.C., the fifty first state? Now, of course. Of
course. Of course. It will almost certainly pass
the House and it will almost certainly go nowhere
in the Senate. Most Republicans have expressed
that they are against making Washington, D.C.
the fifty first state. This would not be and
will not be the first time that the House of
Representatives votes to do this. The House
already approved the D.C. statehood measure
in 2020 by a vote of 232 to 180, but it did
not even come to the floor of the Senate. Now,
in 2020, the Senate was controlled by Republicans.
Democrats now control the Senate. It's 50 50.
Democrats have a majority because by controlling
the White House, Kamala Harris becomes
the tiebreaking 50 first vote in the Senate. But
most legislation needs 60 votes to go forward.
This is not the type of thing making Washington,
D.C. a fifty first state. That's not something
you can move forward on via budget reconciliation
by every analysis that we've seen so far. So you
need to find 10 Republicans, 10 Republicans. And
it is extraordinarily unlikely. We are not aware
of 10 Republicans that want to move forward
with Washington, D.C. as a fifty first state
Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer has committed
to bringing it to the floor for a vote. But again,
this gets back to the filibuster. And when we
talked, what was it, January, maybe February, when
we talked about the possible paths forward on the
filibuster? One of the things that we explained
was even if there's something you could pass
with 50 votes, you still need 60 to end debate.
This is how this is how the filibuster works. And
we talked about some filibuster reforms, making it
a talking filibuster, requiring 40 requiring 40
senators in the Senate to keep debate going at
all times. We've talked about all these things.
None of these changes have been made. And so
we listed D.C. statehood and Puerto Rican
statehood as specific possible issues that
will go nowhere unless some kind of filibuster
reform is done. Well, it's happening now.
Sometime this month, the House is going to vote on
making Washington, D.C., a 50 first state. It is
likely to pass. It will then go to the Senate and
by every indication, there will not even be a vote
on it. Of course, I am in favor of D.C. statehood.
We've talked before about how the population of
Washington, D.C. at 700000 is larger than the
population of the state of Wyoming, which has
two senators. It's larger than the population
of the state of Vermont, which has two senators.
Those in Washington, D.C., have no voting
representation in Congress, but they do have
just as a sort of factual note, Eleanor Holmes
Norton is a representative for Washington,
D.C. in the House, but is a non-voting
delegate. So that's the latest I've said.
I would love to see this issue of D.C. statehood
dealt with in a serious manner by Joe Biden.
The House is going to vote and then it is likely
going to stall in the Senate. And at a certain
point, Democrats and Joe Biden are going to have
to decide, are we committed to getting these
things done to the degree that we are going to
do something about the filibuster, understanding
that any changes they do make to the filibuster
could be a double edged sword that comes back
against them when they are not in control. I
support filibuster reform. I support Washington,
D.C. as a fifty first state. I would love to
hear from you. How should Democrats handle this?